as we enter a summer of uncertainty and
change it's having an impact on mental
health to the school closures learning
online limited contact with friends and
the cancellation of activities is
unsettling it's hard to measure the
scale of the problem because it's still
unfolding experts do say they've seen a
significant increase in demand for
counseling services Canada's largest
Pediatrics Center the Hospital for Sick
Children in Toronto is leading a study
examining the mental health impact of
the co bid 19 measures on children youth
and families
Jennifer Crosby is a clinical
psychologist and health clinician
scientist within the department of
psychiatry at sick kids hospital
professor Crosby thanks for taking time
to speak with us tell me about this
study you're involved in who's taking
part what are you measuring and tracking
absolutely so when the Kovach measures
were put into place very quickly those
of us who are working in mental health
research came together to try to see how
we could understand what the impact is
on children families and youth so four
major mental health studies that were
already happening in Ontario quickly
came together so that we could create a
survey and a mechanism of reaching out
to families virtually and finding out
how they were doing how they were coping
with these emergency measures that were
in place and we're gonna track these
families over the next 12 months because
it's not just about the initial measures
and what the impact was but what's the
impact over time I know there are huge
variations in how kids cope but in broad
terms can you tell us what the studies
revealed so far about the impact the
pandemic has had it's very much in line
with international data that is showing
that children and parents are reporting
an increase across a range of concerns
such as anxiety and mood and
irritability and attention and
concentration really a very large
percentage of respondents have said that
parents have noticed an increase in
these traits from before kovat and also
a lot of uncertainty and worry about
what's going to happen down the line you
know kids especially younger ones tend
to want to know what the plan is what is
happening next with all this uncertainty
now not even knowing if they'll be back
in class in the fall what
does that uncertainty potentially lead
to it has been very difficult and that
uncertainty is a key part of that you
know I think everybody initially when
the emergency measures went into place
there was a families had to cope and
come up with new strategies of dealing
with that and and to some degree I think
that became a new normal for families
but now as we head into summer in school
ends again we have a whole new section
for kids to to kind of think about so by
and large camps are not happening if
they are happening they're happening in
a very different way sport programs not
happening there's still a lot of
uncertainty and you know every day and
every week there's an update and a
change and that uncertainty uncertainty
can be very difficult for kids who's
most at risk of developing mental health
challenges because of this pandemic you
know we don't know the answer to that
and that was really one of the most
important elements of this study is that
this is unprecedented there's so many
factors that we need to consider that
this data is going to really be key in
helping us understand what the impact is
and what would be important moving
forward if perhaps we need to think
about or plan more emergency measures if
there's a second wave or that this goes
on for a longer period of time we're
really hoping that this data is going to
help us plan and perhaps identify the
kids who we should be and the families
and the youth that we should be touching
base with earlier and perhaps providing
targeted interventions to help them cope
and manage better in these uncertain
times
you know kids look to us as role models
how important is it that we manage our
own anxiety and take care of ourselves
and not put too much pressure on
ourselves to plan the perfect summer
absolutely I think that's a really
important message kids do look to adults
as their emotional barometer as such and
so modeling managing our anxieties and
our worries and sort of being in the
moment setting up some routines that
work for your family based on the new
situation prior viding some normalcy
within you know your family life we
can't control what's going to happen in
a month or two months or with school or
with Kovan well you know we can set
aside dinner times
times of days or times in the week when
we play games together things we do as a
family you can really set a new routine
and a new pace within a with a family
and then then kids can really rely on
those expectations and they can oh well
these things these things are gonna stay
stable and so while there's other things
that are maybe a little bit uncertain
these are the things that I can count on
so wherever you live across the country
figuring out what is allowable and then
kind of facilitating and helping kids
get out and reconnect with their social
networks to sort of help them reengage
that part of their life which is so
important to them sick kids is looking
for families from across the country to
participate in the study if you're
interested you can email the team at
kovat mental health at SickKids dot CA